what is up everybody how is it going
Persia here Ritchie is back I'm no
longer flying solo got the co-hosts with
me today
no the homie Richie and today we are
gonna be playing Petey you know Silent
Hill Petey if you guys remember however
a little bit differently if you guys
know just this past Friday dreams was
released and it's a game where you can
create your own games and your own
levels and your own music videos and all
types of really really cool things and
that means obviously people are remaking
some of our favorite games there is
already a Final Fantasy seven one oh
yeah floating around out there
Resident Evil Resident Evil we've got a
lot of Awesome fan-made stages and games
in dreams right now so of course we saw
that PG was up on here and we had to do
it how to do it to him
yes but first things first we will jump
into that gameplay very very soon we for
those of you returning we've been doing
this intro segments here just to talk
about some of the news going on on the
GameSpot website and on our YouTube and
while we let everyone get into the
stream and get ready so that we don't
get started without people who are
showing up a few minutes later settle in
chat with us yes
exactly and the first topic of the day
the sonic movie the song a movie for you
have had has had just the most
ridiculous
timeline of events since its inception
with the whole rework of the graphics
and all that but with all that said it
is still the only well not the only one
but the video game adaptation of a movie
that has the highest status and be best
opening weekend so it made some major
money in the opening weekend despite all
of those graphical issues
you know everything that went down it's
not a chat if you guys have seen it yeah
if you've seen it let us know what you
thought I loved it no spoilers no
spoilers though please okay please fine
it was good though it was great I loved
it I love me some Jim Carrey so yeah it
made 57 million in the opening weekend
oh my gosh passing the detective Pikachu
which was 54 play that's surprising yes
so yeah pretty interesting I would
recommend going to see it if you guys
really want my opinion on it
same here time sonic fan I was telling
exactly and I was telling some of my
friends also you know you gotta take my
opinion with green salt because my bar
for like being satisfied with things is
very low so I just saw Jim Carrey was in
the movie and I was already you know
what I love it 10 out of 10 a little
more critical I'm kind of a snobby film
student and I'm really picky but I also
love Sonic and I would say go watch it
it's good it's like it could have gone
really wrong I think but it turned out
really good especially after they fix
Sonic and of course Jim Carrey like he
steals the show it's great very fun time
and also moving on to our next topic
tomorrow at 6 a.m. Pacific time or 9
a.m. East 98th and Eastern Time there's
gonna be a Nintendo Direct that's gonna
be specifically for the new Animal
Crossing oh yeah so if that is your type
of thing you should definitely check it
out because it looks like they're going
to be showing off an in-depth look at
the desert island getaway package
whatever that may mean I'm not really
sure they're seeing it's gonna be about
a 25-minute long livestream so ya know
just keeping away from the big events
they're doing their own little general
their own little conferences about each
individual thing lately pretty cool I
mean a little by little more people are
like kind of scooting away from III it's
a little sad but I mean we get more new
sprinkled out throughout the year at
least so it's nice this way they
mentioned some plans that they already
have definitely I don't know I didn't
play any Animal Crossing games there's
so many I don't even know where to begin
I mean honestly you could pick up any of
them and be generally like the same feel
I kind of get that vibe so like maybe
one day I'll just pick a random one up
this new one maybe everyone loves this
new one yeah I'm looking forward to it
and I really really love the Animal
Crossing themed switch that they came
out with oh yeah every one of the office
was going crazy about I want it really
super cool so yeah guys I'm gonna go
ahead and link an article in the chat
below now for anybody who wants to get
more details about the Nintendo Direct
where you can watch it tomorrow and all
of that jazz and be sure to just tune in
to our website gamespot.com for news
articles reviews content of seeds we
have ton of videos on the site and on
our youtube channel covering a wide
variety of different things new things
coming out every day so make sure you
check that out all right you guys it
looks like we've got a nice group of
people in here ready to check out this
week ET remake it's like a remake of a
demo yeah that might be turning into a
nightmare for rich oh yeah
the fun thing about this yeah the fun
thing about this is I played it before I
love it so much I love watching people
play it also Ritchie's never played the
original PC demo so this is gonna be
extra fun yeah so try not to spoil it
for him he may need some helps and some
tips along the way I did here it's not a
true one-to-one remake but it's probably
as close as it's gonna get so yeah I'm
excited the ground up very cool yes and
it looks really good so let's go ahead
and hop on over to the game you can find
this in your dreams
surfing dashboard on dreams you just
search PT should be one of the first
ones that comes up already got almost
25,000 thumbs up yeah this one's by
Lewis C 729 if you're ready I'm ready
I believe we are ready okay I haven't
downloaded tree okay so that little
middle controller button in the middle
of the screen
oh yeah you have to you move the
controller to move every game every
interface not when you're in the in the
dashboard so yeah I don't wish me luck
y'all Persia you have played I was not
part of the PlayStation nation yet when
this came out originally so god speed
here I go
it's just gonna we were talking about
this before we started in how it's gonna
be kind of funny that these creatures
probably won't be as scary as the real
deal with blur but here we go
it was really good sounds good too happy
Tuesday Brandon it's Wednesday hi
Brandon hold my virtual hand Brandon I'm
just messing with the controls that are
displayed on the bottom left already has
the brightness all the way up I did walk
around a little bit this is the Mario
[ __ ] right here I got to do it the
right way
Kotetsu in the chest jeans pretty
awesome
I've seen people create a new crash game
and even sonic adventures 3 yes you guys
it is adventure 3 it's amazing the
things that people have been creating
it's not extreme with Sonic Xtreme was
put on there I'm talking because I'm
freaking out but that was a game that
was never released on the Sega
looks very good actually yeah doing
something wrong already you guys know
just takes a bit of wandering around and
looking at certain things to unlock
[Music]
before it just not white it's getting
harder and harder to write and greens
and a good question up Media Molecule
come under legal fire if someone were to
remake a game or use intellectual
property I think since everything is
community made and made by the fans that
is you know I don't know if the dreams
that the Media Molecule can get in
trouble for that because these are all
community made and family things it's
not them specifically making it so say
your says love from Lebanon guys thanks
for joining us Marcus said the follow up
for me creation was amazing I did see
that I haven't played yet it looks
really really good
yeah screenshots TV told me about that
this morning
[Music]
first laughing at me Radio stop now I'm
hearing heavy breathing oh this all this
might even be worse because it's not
meant to look scary but it's dirty it's
scary anyway great someone was right
here and the light went off motivation
hustle says is this live yes no you were
telling me to husband oh we do have a
little bit of a stream delay though so
please give us about 30 to 45 seconds to
answer it's like every little thing just
becomes so creepy right yeah that was
just yeah that that ability I think
Suzanne so dark it is really tight
I'm like one yet yeah James is the name
of the game everything stopped oh now
it's open again zero four eight six
three remember the numbers Mason what
are their mean
[Music]
now for those of you who haven't played
the PT demo it was actually really
complicated really yeah I'm curious if
some of you can adjust the I think it's
already
[Music]
[Applause]
single handedly may be scared and I've
never played it in a progress you guys
[Music]
[Laughter]
boys I guess that was the baby in
question Kojima loves babies right
babies so dark so dark a kid see it's
making me looking at you look at it
like into the shower wall so dark the
doors open there we go good yeah
have you guys seen oh man I forgot his
name
but there's this on YouTube and he
basically goes into the PT that the real
PT demo and finds all this hidden stuff
oh yeah she says he goes outside of the
borders of the game doesn't that we talk
about yeah yeah yeah cool stuff and he
found out that like Lisa is always right
behind you in the game like all the time
Lisa doesn't mean anything to you behind
me is scary enough
Oh red so that must be yeah back at it
again it didn't like reset the whole
thing my progress
I love that movie I watch that movie in
a theater really good like Groundhog's
Day the
[Music]
and stop showing up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you guys you know when people are like
oh man I wish I make PT again and then
the other person like yeah in your
dreams the facts come out so the cool
thing so all these things you're finding
this is actually good you should make a
mental note like mental homework but in
the demo these pieces were so small oh
really
you would be like that's what I was
looking for the whole time I feel like
that already
sorry screen if you don't know this is
my first time playing this Burgess
played it I mean imagine this but in VR
horror games in VR Sam's baby
nobody said yes they did Roger and
welcome back good to see you Bob Jones
if you're wondering if this is peachy
it's not it's a creative tool game well
dreams exclusively for the ps4 and is
now available amazing gonna be in the
same day
well I'll get as close as I can to all
of them that's two of them there's one
more over here somewhere
this is full speed by the way yeah I did
notice that in a few energy yeah there
you go see you picked it up you saw that
little choice so Wow try to do that with
all the piece of you found so far okay I
can only think of three sorry for anyone
watching it's like spinning around like
a madman the portal player says did you
guys watch Sonic movie yes we did
yeah I loved it there we go okay three
and then that everyone by the door
oh yeah well I'm getting the full
experience here you guys were your first
time playing are you got a few more okay
I'm gonna go back then so dark show The
Dream's menu before we sign off for the
day we'll go back to the menu and give
you guys a look-see at the dashboard
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm pretty sure there's one over by the
pail of my phone ooh telephone Saxum up
all grandpa Richie that's me being a
grandpa yeah member uh well suited that
one on the floor that you just looked at
right me and David were playing one time
and I got the nickname there it is
grandpa Richie and he's young and young
and Dave drugs everywhere and all these
empty bottles what a night okay so I
have four or five now before I can't go
back into the bathroom remember you guys
remember how many pieces in total there
were I think there was also one in a
picture oh I don't think it'll be in
this one but there is even one and guys
correct me if I'm wrong there was one in
the pause menu really yeah that's how
while but I don't think there's a pause
in this so that was probably not gonna
be in here but that's how crazy the demo
was it was like really whoever did final
you're a genius
they make you snoop man you did get that
one that was on the floor behind you by
the clock right that was like your first
one you guys yeah I was over here what
about over oh yeah you got any more
pills
what is the search name for this asks
nerdy gamer if you go into the dashboard
just type in PP 104 I think it was
called my mom if you just yeah and if
you just either search the person or
just PT by itself it will be in that
list this one is by Louis c79 all right
guys it's like favorite thing oh yeah no
that's just the the crown molding there
however I would not have been surprised
if it was something like that there was
some there was another one
was it all funny no Marie
now that I know what to do I'm gonna be
really vigilant I wish I could get back
into the bathroom but if they're not
letting me it's probably for a reason
you might have found them all since the
one in the main meeting is probably not
gonna be in this okay let's give it a
shot
will it reset if I don't do you remember
what's on the table next to the picture
for you here Akash yes there is another
PT related game that starts after the
ending of this demo where we've seen
Norman Reedus like walking outside there
is also a version like that on the dream
dashboard - all right let's go let's go
just checking one last time I think I
have a total of four okay reset there's
one there dang it you guys help me out
in check I think you're sick of this
help me I'm sick of me I thought there
was one in a picture frame somewhere
baby
can I turn off this I like
man I can't wait till October and so we
could do another spooky month yeah that
really actually did help us oh it's in
the plant
glitch in the matrix right there okay
now we can go get five I think okay -
there's that one next to the bottles
down there itty bitty team right there
come on that was yes Akash
I'm definitely Misha what's your
favorite horror game of all time if I'm
gonna talk about games that actually
made me really scared and slender the
arrival is probably the most scared we
have a
Avadh of that if you want to see that
day just make sure you turn the volume
down because I let's play okay I think
that was all of them let me just check
one more time I feel like I miss one at
the beginning
I can't remember if there was a special
action after you got them I guess we'll
see here in the demo there's also a part
where you have to actually use the
PlayStation microphone and talk into it
Wow so I don't think that's gonna be in
here either but there was there was so
much in that demo and the fact that it
was a demo groundbreaking ok I'm gonna
go for it I think we have them all right
well that was five total if it doesn't
work then at least we know where they
are it doesn't work I will contact Louis
see and if you guys would like to
he was just that kind of guy but then
one day he goes and killed us all
couldn't even be original about the way
he did I'm not complaining I was dying
anyway
[Music]
but yes what I will be coming back and
I'm bringing my new toys with me um I
wonder if he just ended it there might
be I mean there's more to it but that
sounded like the end of this level I
mean makes sense can't expect the entire
things work in progress there you go you
see on the bottom left who is Connor 13
on Twitter for updates we've also
included the link to this game page in
the description so if you open that up
you will be able to see the user and the
link to the page itself if you want to
go and download it and check it out on
that page they show up you know where
they pulled reverend stuff and air all
the other contributors to this level so
yeah pretty good for a fan-made thing we
can go check out some of the other PT
remake you'd like in fact if you want to
play the next one all you I don't know
maybe someone else brought it up in the
chat
of the other sea all I did all duty and
for those of you who wanted to see the
dreams dashboard this is just the search
portal but I'll show you the rest of it
later
so yeah TPT they have second floor most
of these will be work in progress the
game just officially released this past
Friday so this was the one we just
played which has the most likes 24k but
there's a lot of different versions do
there now if I ever play the real one Oh
a long process to get that done to be
honest Lucas asks what's dreams so
dreams is like a create your own game
it's like a studio type of game for the
PlayStation 4 that lets you make games
from the ground up sort of and including
your own music and so what a lot of fans
are doing are remaking games like PT and
I've seen Metal Gear Solid a lot of
games are being remade by fans on this
platform so I think I'm gonna download
dreams I don't know if I have the skill
to build something but I definitely want
to keep playing what fans are making
it's pretty cool
so someone in chat mentioned this
earlier so since we do have extra time
after we finished our first level we're
gonna play through this one so this one
picks up where the demo in
[Laughter]
kind of games yeah he was just that kind
of guy but then one day he goes and
kills us all
he couldn't even be original about the
way he did I'm not complaining
I was dying a word in any way to play
toys with me oh boy
yes Oh spoiler alert at the end of the
demo you finally leave that house and
you walk outside and then it pans up
like this and then you find out you were
Norman Reedus cold
I love that in-game model it's just like
the trailer you are in silence honestly
I was really sad promise
you know the features from dream wow
pretty dedicated so far man great
everything I've seen on dreams I bought
I've been impressed
[Music]
it's so cool because I don't have any
coding experience or anything like that
I really feel like I cool
our very own Benji okay they played a
little bit on communal Friday last week
got you so
definitely check that out a little bit
and maybe check out some of the other
[Laughter]
swamped that's what we are we're getting
fuller just like this per week now and
the government's cutting our budget I'm
telling you tempura we can't do our job
this way well that's why I'm here for
you I need to play more of this in the
creative so I can really understand all
the voice acting and everything like
that Henry Sullivan the Chinese family
upended last night then hung himself in
the quarry
it's an awful story but the dear God
it's just getting worse it's like the
whole city is losing its fine
so what now the husband had an
acquaintance that's here and want to
talk to us he's upstairs let's go
let's go in a game in which you meet
games can you make a game that makes you
says Emma succeeds Evan I think it would
just break my brain just broke this guy
is creepy what's your name sir Tom
Sanders you related to Colonel Sanders
how well did you know him we go back a
long time I can assure you officer this
is not like him at all
did he seem different lately he had been
down for a while after losing his job
but that was nothing new this just came
so suddenly any possible I was mashing I
can't think of any okay
definitely could you tell us about it's
strange though it's happening everywhere
now doesn't it
all over town yeah it's a real head
buster I'll give you that but maybe it
shouldn't surprise us oh yeah why is
that
like scary in a different way people
seemed so an edge human economies going
through tough times takes more than that
to start a riot like this it could be
more to it than just then I'm sorry
exactly how did you know Henry Sullivan
this is a pretty long caffeine fan-made
yeah oh yeah the photos of the crime
scene I asked for there in the photo
land we better go take a look it sounds
like the top later time guy just in a
couple different at least yeah at least
two of the guys the same guy still
though impressive like the less amount
of people
the more impressive it gets you remember
that was on the wall yeah when we were
inside the house near the front door now
I just hear Tommy Wiseau told me from
Hell forgive me Lisa there's some
monster inside of me oh boy oh they
always write those things
I sent more info on this guy - you're
here you're living in that hotel yeah
there now I'll check out the info all
right
see you later
I'm not sure how I feel about this yet
to be honest
[Music]
that was definitely in the supreme
it kind of takes domestic homicide
unrelated though it could be part of a
larger trend such as employment
childcare
[Music]
you're right
it dreams supreme is oasis this is a
little more extensive the well like you
said it's a continuation of what I just
blade and you know this isn't really
like a remake of its job there's really
no expectations their jobs
wait there was a thing between the
manager and her trying to associate this
voice with Norman Reedus is it's a lot
for my brain to try to compute well why
kill the children
hmm the total zero four eight six three
[Laughter]
it's like you didn't even want to deal
with that ignore that this wasn't like
you was it denry then how much of this
level did you guys pull he doesn't hear
that okay yeah I get to walk around now
that strut I know he's like yes I am
Norman Reedus what was that I better get
scared soon selling this thing
let's walk it's got some qua pipes to
these steps
Cody asses poopy goes oooh nice long
poorly lit hallway so many doors am i
funny am i funny - you sound like Joe
Pesci my clown do I amuse you he slits
through the wall yeah I saw the other
side oh this one
so was the demo like in the style that I
played was the real demo didn't end in
the house this is all just creating or
was this ended in that scene where he
walked out on the show it ended right
there so the fans are just making yeah
they're just making the continuation Wow
unless there was something somewhere
that explained where the story in line I
haven't seen it I haven't researched as
I don't know so as far as I know this is
like 100% fans yeah you guys let me know
in the chat hey you okay hey okay
our headphones are like boosted oh it's
it's a paternal it's Tom but he looks
younger well he has brown hair Sanders
he had white hair when we were Tom Tom
Sanders it's me Jeffrey Harper from the
station I heard crying crying I thought
I was thinking of dumb down it's gonna
kill you now sorry I no time to hon you
know yeah I forgot we were in a hotel I
have a flower in him
we are currently buying on PlayStation -
oh it's so strange - he's got me
thinking this effect supposed to plant a
flower and it grows Wow you take a seat
for this is some good she's beautiful of
cinematic language talking about flowers
is that new flower the same thought why
not you see it's not so simple suppose
suppose that the Henry Sullivan that
murdered his family wasn't the same
Henry Sullivan like you are I knew
before I sure the question your recipe
yeah it's only Wednesday this is less
like a game and more like a like a
telltale style
sure yeah choose your own adventure
no no really where where oh no bleep bro
oh he lost his his eyelids from the last
time we spoke oh my god not uncommon
these days he's so good blink bro that
reminds me of a few things have you ever
heard of the flowers flowers I have
looked up on this town it has a
fascinating
apparently the flowers wasn't angel I
love that the teeth move but not the
lips somehow in his eyes nothing this
time a group of people took possession
of it and used it for unknown purposes
this was apparently 80 years ago where
are you going he's holding it all the
music stopped yeah I guess I I guess I'm
just grasping at straws Tom you're tired
you've been through a lot definitely
giving me nightmares
[Music]
alright I guess I'm uh are you going
back or forward oh I can't the invisible
walls it's alright we could run he's a
he's a that's the strut is the best
akash said the way thomas animated goes
with this creepy vibe true that door
looks cracked open hmm okay that's
enough work for today we're gonna sleep
i'm not moving this
you just hover that's just part of the
cutscene
what is that freddy mercury in the jet
oh snap dreaming about the floros
can you move oh no it's still part of
the cutscenes are
[Music]
I don't like it here
[Applause]
this isn't in and what is up those
eyebrows Oh No
are we back in the house
[Music]
we're seeing this
Henry
- I'll say this guy was quite the poser
sir it's yeah what is it's this door oh
no oh no you mean that bathroom
alright this is pretty good now not
gonna lie that simple wasn't every four
sir it's true
I'm impressed
floros this door won't budge sir yeah
alright Jim get the battery on the other
side of door blocking dark am I dreaming
you tell us man for real
we're tripping who are you who are you
I think they meant the bathroom door oh
you controller told me to look in the
gap at the door all you can hear the
footsteps Oh Lord you do it it's me
Henry Henry Sullivan I didn't do it
I didn't kill them
none of us did I woke up two days ago I
walked down the hallway and then I saw
me walking in front of myself but it
wasn't really me you have got to
convince the others you have got to save
me I don't want to be trapped here just
in case the controller talks to me now
oh my gosh we're back in the house all
right dark over there so we already know
what time it is yeah little writing new
writing okay no that's what was said on
the other wall right forgive me Lisa
like a rap song where are you
[Music]
when if you walk you forward by
[Laughter]
[Music]
annoying
[Music]
controlling this goodness that was loud
Wayne Hart is he holding a glass tell me
about it Jeffery we're heading to
Henry's house there's more things we
need to look into right now yeah right
now hurry up we're waiting for you feel
like the fact that it's still going like
it's a pretty long level yeah
[Music]
sure said no silent hill's game ever
unbelievable power outage
Haga lo people see pretty piled up
[Music]
let's just hope we get there in one
piece
yeah mommy knows I was thinking the same
thing they put a lot of work into this
this is extensive in such a short amount
of time unless this was in the beta also
because dreams had the beta for a long
time all right here we are let's head on
inside
no thanks
famous last words yeah okay well at
least we know the lay house funny I had
a dream about this place last night you
too huh only that yeah you totally yeah
it was foggy I stood by the window and
you were talking with Jim and Charles
about something yeah I'm real brave now
I'm like what up door I got the cops
here and I'll send the room watching us
well to see you know anyway not much
else happened I woke up and felt
exhausted for some reason
okay looks like this guy was quite the
Busan now we're repeating ourselves now
they're gonna look at the drawing on the
wall Oh sir
[Music]
oh we deported
[Music]
are you going not again Oh going the
other way
hey Jeffrey come here whoa interesting
okay
I suppose simple recognize the bottom of
a rocket ship what is it what was that
thing called he was talking about the
other church like multiple angles for
the cinematic creaky door yeah anyone
else here yeah so come with definitely
that door we were looking at the
bathroom door the creepy one this one
over here
oh yeah it's open sounds like the end of
doom too
coordinated shots always began to radio
[Music]
there's a Beeman in it what kind of
language is that - its Swedish sir these
dicks leadership I do sir nice meeting
in King that's messed up
he's like oh you speak Swedish all right
let's take this back to the station to
speak with the language expert not you
are you but the language help me right
here right now but we're gonna take it
back because you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
get to a new dimension
[Music]
hisham afraid to t Wallaby Way Sydney
cool guy was freaking out death
stranding and dreams win I did fun in
there already action yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
are you gonna tell us Tom I was I didn't
get to see like you saw something the
numbers were a form of music where is
the other Church located I'm not sure
how can you not be sure
look I already told you what I know Mac
[Music]
music you see here
[Music]
coming with us slow fade to black
oh boy Wow this elevator right it's kind
of great that you could tell that they
just made a room and moved it so it
looked like an elevator yeah but I get
it you know we all know it's an how did
they get all the dialogue that's what
I'm wondering
to be honest cuz there's a lot of
cutscenes in this right I haven't played
dreams yet so I don't know anything
about anything yeah that's true I still
love it Tom needs to tell about first
where you going oh yeah me too
yo don't get boggy if he gets destroyed
by something
showing this are three maybe that was
out there Tom Tom back over here in tom
is not here oh-ho it scared me a little
bit he's got a like a stumble
I don't like Tom's behavior you doing oh
your arm
that scared me I got some good tea pose
oh man no Tom you go in there report
back yeah you go first I'm so shocked by
how long Moses
[Music]
it seems likely should we all go in we
can all fit oh we don't know what so
yeah ha one of us should go is go ahead
when it draw straws who has for us we'll
stay in contact over the radio all right
good luck
[Music]
nope
those sounds are not good either they're
they're unsettling exactly I'm sure we
oh man like we're crawling oh it's like
Coraline it feels like it's getting
longer I don't know if that's just my
mind playing it's like the lighting
effect his lights kind of moving I think
I saw you wait wait why didn't Tom go in
here yeah are you like good detective
why are we in here everyone was calling
you sir bad news
this is a long tunnel nope no he sounds
like the peanuts teacher
[Music]
we should have turn around yeah wonder
what happens if you cancel everything
else I just go back me like yo I seen
some stuff I've seen enough all right
the controller was talking to me again
so shine and get it in the mic Oh a
little wisp thing Oh
I'm walking something oh you're in
control again I thought it was like a
temple of what's this what now he's here
could that really be the flowers
[Music]
the flowers Tom Sanders talked about
this thing I think he tried to break
into the death of Henry and his family
where is he now by the way in the back
Oh yo
[Music]
traitor
dang he totally knocked us out but why
are we now oh this looks like the front
desk of the floros Club worried we're
just chillin if that leaves have you
chillin with Lisa right yo she was
watching over us while we were asleep
and that's all see you Brandon thanks
for joining us today see you later
closes what the heck is yeah my thoughts
exactly
so if you're just tuning in with us
right now we played a remake of the PT
demo that was me and by Lewis in the end
dreams and then now we're playing
another PG extension I guess this takes
place after the demo also a fan main
thing I believe the users name is dr.
Jones
[Music]
all right she looks awfully fee but
she just said that's her baby she got
shot in the stomach
yeah I'm less scared of her now unless
she jumps out of even and you're real
close know what that was all about me
either but I think we just miss dead
Lisa yeah and now I have a mark on my
head oh that's from the wood plank from
our traitor cop friend are you awake
is he in jail how you gonna knock me out
and then lock me up Napoleon in the
chest is hello from the Philippines
welcome sir what are you talking about I
saw you go in there I'm the ground
saying that a likely story
I don't know I don't believe you
I don't know why are we all in cells
where's Tom
it was tell no idea listen you got to
get me out of here there's a bunch of
keys in my office on the third floor
no one are responding to radio or phone
calls the person attacking me could
still be in here grab that plant you'll
find a proper weapon upstairs we're
chilling I need a minute here it's
relaxing a bit been through a lot oh all
right so you're armed with the play I
wonder where you're gonna have to fight
against you know I can't hit my
girlfriend Lisa we just got to first
base I still cannot believe I was weird
and Geoffrey was with it he was like oh
yeah it's like okay am I supposed to get
them out of the gel sale you say you'll
find a weapon upstairs and the keys but
there's no there's no staircase yet or
any way up is that full speed Oh must be
huh so dark Hey is it an elevator switch
Oh
is it working how many I get is walk
into this yeah sometimes I just be doing
too much elastic elevator ya know the
elevator works
nice we needed that just just to remind
us we were in an elevator
alright my head is still bleeding we're
trying to go upstairs
if Pyramid Head in this I don't think so
that'd be cool that'd be a fun cameo huh
what would we rate dreams
well Whangdoodle levels has been pretty
fun so far but I haven't sat down and I
can't created something yet I mean there
I don't have nearly enough experience
[Music]
this is the time to go get the homies
out
oh yes we're not going back in there let
us know in the chat what else have you
guys seen on in dreams I've only seen a
little but I was pretty impressed
early on they during the beta someone
made a Resident Evil and Oh Metal Gear
Solid we have company hi hi oh you ready
oh yeah take that I can't move the
camera Engel so this is this is what
we're working with here another one why
do they got a knife yeah what it
wouldn't point seems hardly fair
oh you're browsing I think you were
getting hurt oh man I am kind of oh no I
think you were that's so weird is like
bear it like didn't even look like it
registered as a hit I think you're a
little slower now oh holy what's so many
doors
can I leave me with the plank so many
doors you can add trophies to the game I
think I had seen something Oh more bad
guys looks like your health regenerated
yeah maybe when I walk through the door
so he said you need the keys which you
got and a weapon look at that they're
both right there the gap and the keys
are you did it equip
[Music]
freeze whoa Oh is that Lou oh it's fake
Lou that was the Lou that knocked us out
how was he seeing this I think whoa
start with his arms oh they're about to
get destroyed
the dude is a flamethrower oh no he has
tentacles now oh shoot him now
[Applause]
dang what's going on here yeah you're
definitely right Akash they're really
good levels I don't trust that that
things go what are you talking about the
real lose trapped downstairs in the cage
all right we'll follow you lead the way
man they believe that room
[Applause]
I knew that guy was gonna go first
whoa I need that gift
I need that give him with the loan I
needed throughout the fight I need r1 to
aim execute got this
[Music]
okay I don't know if I can run a run
very fast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay baby I need to go pick something
something you have to reload by pressing
a different button
I think I just wasted three buttons for
Bullock's format
okay
I love this music I love everything
going on I know
Oh dr. Garber I need the light Norman
run
all right let me sit up a little bit is
this still PC and in period in theory
hold up
those sounded like they thin
back to you up with you in I'm dying
over here I'm really glad I'm not
playing this one from zero to 100 all
right if I just died his mouth
all right
maybe sure what you're supposed to be
aiming at me yeah I don't know if you
have enough bullets I don't know what I
don't know anything
Oh
[Music]
yeah I've downloaded your pattern so I
was cheated
that's a fine line for silent Hills
[Music]
is it me or DS never read dawn really
straight up
I think it's just a lighting effect you
like pausing briefly yeah looks like
it's like taking damage shoot the belly
okay okay okay okay so I have to wait
till you run
you
Oh
[Music]
however
I'm trying to make every no no why is
Norman Reedus
so slow oh my god
[Music]
oh my goodness
I hear squishy affect me - it sounds
like a hit but chat is saying maybe she
with the blood yeah the big apparently
this problem has come up the letter you
said he reach done he contacted the
creator of this
[Music]
well it's good there's a nice feedback
system a dream yeah there is he can
comment on stuff you can like notify
people of any bugs
there's one big one right here yeah
we're trying to kill No
[Music]
Hey
Oh
ah neither red spot hombre
goodness okay okay good
I got speaker to see how we have seven
minutes
okay
sorry that's like the only shot you
[Music]
oh no no a little wobble
no there's no reload button or anything
we tried
there you go there you go perfect
No
Crouch I don't think silicon
the legs don't hurt me so
I can't cry
[Music]
[Music]
I don't like those dips of damage
unless you run out of bullets
alright alright
don't go so close I'm scaring you it's
scaring me too but I just gotta say
close like when you're aiming like that
you look up
goes whichever direction he's facing
[Music]
[Music]
also okay you're right it is only left I
was like let me switch it up you're
under there right
oh my
gotcha nice
how many shot
go
[Music]
all right here octopus no it's probably
that one over here buddy
oh you're tellin
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
oh wow
old gamer yeah this this is a dart game
this boss by specifically
any day now spider boy
Oh ball man I need to go to the light
[Music]
No
Derek in the chat says like playing from
software game hospital or no joke
[Music]
yeah
it suits our daughters spider-boy
I feel like I run toward the light and I
turn around I'm still in the dark
yeah
[Music]
who Laura this spot
oh my god
[Music]
he's so yeah
q I was wondering I was like I have no
keys here unload
[Music]
one minute to spare music - white was
that the enemy I think so if you if that
is that's perfect freakin time after I
just feel the big clinical spider I
where did you go I went to you
where are you the one talking to me just
now the spider
toasters
I'm Jeffrey hark
thank you I just like using it so the
guys I guess there's someone else in a
room with us who the person is staring
at us right now
oh okay yeah don't rope me into this way
[Music]
outside the screen right here straight
up breaking the controller the
controller talked to Persia oh I can't
see anything in here the other person
who sees us
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's time to leave Jeffrey I'm moving
him Oh take apart [ __ ] right here
the door has opened you defeated Espada
this delayed the decay of solitaire
[Music]
witness
I would be so shocked epistemically yeah
yo
[Music]
sounds like doom
I pressed it r1
forgive me Lisa
[Music]
even though you're tearing us apart
[Music]
the controller keeps talking to us I
know I'm trying to catch it
nothing's happening right now though
there we go gosh
what is going
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right then
much more creepy yeah it's like death
string
we should be ending right now but I am
hooked
captivating
me too this is so strange can you make
it to Lisa I'm trying to it's getting
really dark oh okay
the controller knows all
[Music]
Wow
yo kudos see this level
[Music]
but we know
[Music]
Wow
all right you guys I think on that note
we are gonna have to call it a day
weirdo I mean I don't know if it still
continues on or not but we're definitely
past time however I didn't have a ton of
fun please
all these community made levels
I'm also slowly dragging the Salian
folks that we just keep it finally
because of loser right we're we're all
good I feel like we're close we are
straight of a meteor right now
but yeah you guys thank you so much for
tuning in and playing some dreams with
us not only a really fun time this game
is awesome
I'm gonna go ahead and pause it right
there whoo that was a good time I'm not
gonna lie it was pretty great
from the Pitti remake made by Lewis I
believe yeah see and then you know dr.
Jones here making the silent hill's you
know post PT demo games crazy all in all
great time a lot of fun and I hope you
guys enjoyed it as well if you're
interested in playing these then go
ahead and pick up dreams because not
only will you be able to play these
levels but you'll be able to play all
the community made levels and even make
some levels of your own so all the
aspiring game devs out there is your
chance your chance so yeah thank you
guys so much for tuning in be sure to
tune in with us every weekday we usually
go live at 11 a.m. but we had to push
things back a little bit we may be
fiddling around with the possibility of
having a 2 p.m. stream on weekdays
everyday but until that time comes 11
a.m. Pacific time is when you can catch
us thanks for joining us in we will see
ya mañana
[Music]
you